creation film everyone I not do they
thank their yeah so today we will take a
little game of would you runners and
camera ready and go yeah okay so the
first one we're going pretty easy would
you rather have your bachelorette party
in New York or Miami you aren't new you
are the offense made me but yeah what
would you do I would like to have a nice
dinner
saucy cocktails everybody could have
dressed up and then I think is he fun to
go to like a hip-hop Club and do it a
night of dancing do a bit of bottle sir
business and then maybe like afterwards
we could do like a little outdoor party
like either sleepover thing or like hip
a situation and do maybe like a nice
little spa thing I love honest a copy to
me Tampa I would go to a small filthy
empty karaoke oh yeah Wow if you go to
karaoke and kick everyone else out and
you know perform till the night was done
and what was your karaoke so I tend to
prefer rapping just because I feel
self-conscious about my range I want to
for you Hollywood and we keep rather
your boyfriend or girlfriend watch
videos your craziest girls my eye or
your parents watch it my partner my
partner here probably of my girls night
out
yeah the craziest goes where but I guess
my parents because there seems to Adam
they'd be like all right you know that
I'm like really gonna judge like they're
like crazy can it was your partner could
be kind of like they might get a look at
you your parents are gonna stop loving
you right stop being your parent right
whereas a boyfriend might be like what
were you guys doing I start to judge you
in a little bit you're a man I have a
little yes birth parents
anchors you rather wake up after a night
with Ryan Gosling or Leonardo DiCaprio
Ryan Franklin yeah Oh Leonardo DiCaprio
would ear
Wow ryan gosling right I mean tight
Eggman I mean yeah it can be out of here
i mean i eleventeen is Romeo and Juliet
has just come out yes in order to cast
Ryan Gosling I wouldn't have to write
anywhere in Ireland which film run if
you got any type C on the pan-fried time
or place and the really baby Ryan
Gosling cute little baby right mr. Brian
oh god I would would you rather start to
Justin Bieber there is dancin yeah
Douglas yes or a moment or so weekend or
repeat for three hours straight
Bieber Justin Bieber Steve Revis
belieber paper for how many hours
three great Bieber what kind of be the
songs you into this
I don't know that merge or we just
forced to listen to them you're just
supposed to dump today
oh we've to dance for three hours oh
there was both I like one theny what was
the one sorry sorry yeah I like that I
would even go to his first album oh so
good it was really good
Janice's great song not baby not that
one but but the other ones on that album
are like oh good what is that one time
dispersal an attack on stewin allowed
and would you rather get a drunken
tattoo okay why do you look at me with
Abed or get so wasted that you shave all
your hair off
including your iPad Ashley oh my gosh
that difference really this is really
hard at times even I mentioned to tattoo
and I said whatever it the other thing
is is what I would do but to shave one's
eyebrows even though it's a temporary
situation
Oh Masha you gave a great tattoo what
have you made a good choice you don't
know how or never about the tattoo yeah
y-yeah bothered think about that one is
a sheet on your head and around wait
wait don't score back so quickly but the
head a brand you hire know I would
regret giving on but you don't know
that's like Caitlyn whatever
I can shoot my hair - back when you have
her get me Maria at my rel Pacific
answer or darker eyebrows or an X I can
come over there has to be like along
with mum oh wow
okay let's come down some Oh like I'm
long enough where the [ __ ] stamp is now
funny and okay I guess I met the one
that has like a dolphin here I do like
tell ya
hell yeah hell yeah oh yeah hi Travis
and would you rather a taquito show
every day for the rest of your life
wouldn't never drink again
you know Shia every day now record
Michaela shot one shot it's like not
even doing it I don't think it's like
fiber can yeah every cue is good - never
again no I couldn't
well organs one shot obviously my I
would be like apple cider vinegar
similar I had a job you once and I it
took me five days to come back okay I
swear to God you look there at entrance
I only drink from a penis drool for the
rest of your life I only drink or wear
fluffy handcuffs for every special
occasion
pyaara pyaara are the hands cuffed
together
no not even it still sucks it is like
that's not like a little bit ruining
around my nose anything yeah penis
travina head problem okay there's a
conversation starter yeah yeah and
accept me no cat stripper
after bachelorette party or wake up with
one the next morning
knock out knock out I think wake up I
don't like violence after the Bentley an
accident was he dead no just not about
if you can knock out just god I feel
terrible
yes you're okay don't know you really
beautiful I was excited to get out any
frightening right I do it doesn't mean
that okay well do you mean after I feel
like we're like other were things that
we like because you're human being okay
I know but it doesn't even necessarily
mean that you had text to this person
that's amazing but they're in your bed
you stayed up all night
the only thing I've heard of that day
happened did you sleep
I'd still I'd still rather right
everything clear III awesome mom I
support dances